I don't think you know there's a girl on
my on my I need to be careful sometimes
you'll be finding these people there's a
girl on I was on three different teams
so there's a girl on a team I was on in
college yeah and literally she was a
girl next door you would never know she
seemed like the sweetest chick and I
swear to God she had a a guy she dated
her freshman year of college did him for
a month he cheated he was like all
around town or whatever her senior year
um she was with a guy that bought her
bought her a house she moved in and I
was like yeah yeah I've told it before
and I was at a party and literally like
her and her body wasn't on Instagram she
was a school teacher good with kids
sweet nice like and literally she was in
the bathroom with the guy from freshman
year at the party her boyfriend came to
um
he bought her house he bought her
exactly she doesn't respect him and that
was kind of a red pill moment for me
where I was like God damn you would
never know